Once you've learned how to parse JSON
data, it's pretty straightforward to
be able to parse the rest
of the fields that we need.
Since this isn't a course on Java or
JSON, we're going to provide you with
the parsing code in the gist below.
And this is what the gist looks like.
There are three helper methods.
The first is for formatting dates.
The second is for rounding temperatures.
The third is returning a forecast JSON
string into an array of forecasts.
This method also handles associating
a date with each forecast entry.
We start with a current date, and we
increment one for each successive day.
Notice that we also use Julian dates,
which is the number of
days that have passed since
the beginning of the Julian period.
More information is in
the instructor notes below, but
it's how we'll consistently
deal with dates in our app.
That way, when comparing dates,
we don't have to worry about taking into
account time zones or
daylight savings time.
Update the fetch weather tasks to
use these helper functions and
the doInBackground method should
return a string array of forecasts.
You can log the output to check
that the array is correct.
The format of one day's
forecast should look like this.